Great, good morning. So, today we are
doing Karl Marx. And Karl Marx is one
most influential thinkers in human
history. His contribution
um to intellectual thought cannot be
um overstated, okay? So, um what I'm
going to do first is I'm going to do a
thought experiment.
Okay? It's just It's just going to be a
fun experiment. And let's pretend
there are two scenarios.
Okay? In scenario one,
you get into a really good college, and
you decide to become a lawyer.
You go to law school, you do extremely
well, you become a lawyer, and you make
a lot of money.
You make a lot of money, you can buy a
big house, go on vacations to
uh Bali,
um
you can you can um have a BMW, okay? So,
that's situation one. You're You're a
super lawyer, basically.
Situation two is different.
You're on a plane with strangers,
and there's about 100 of you, you crash
on an island.
This island, it's very poor, very scarce
resources,
and you have to work together in order
to just get by, okay? You're not eating
well, you're not living well, every day
is a struggle. You're not really sure if
you'll get to the second day.
All right? So, those are the two
scenarios.
You're on an island, and you're
basically like starving.
And so, the question the thought
experiment is, do you think you'd be a
happier person in the first situation or
the second situation?
Now, you Of course, one. Yeah, so you
would think obviously the answer is
number one, but um what I will show you
today is that's not necessarily true,
okay? Maybe for
some of us the answer is number one, but
for many of us, the answer is actually
number two. Because as humans, we want
to feel as though we're with a purpose
in life, and that we are part of a
larger mission to change the world for
the better.
Okay, and that's the underlying thesis
of Karl Marx. All right. So, let's start
with Marx. Okay, so for us to understand
Marx, we first need to review Kant and
Hegel, which we did last class. So,
Immanuel Kant. Immanuel Kant's um theory
of the world is this: We're all endowed
with the capacity to reason.
Okay, and it's born in us.
Um we don't learn it. It is just part of
who we are.
Okay? So, and then this reason interacts
with reality.
The things in themselves. And then what
we see is the appearance.
Okay? So, the crucial argument that Kant
is making is we imagine reality around
us by bringing space and time. Reality
we do we don't see a reality
objectively.
Okay? Or away from us, we see reality as
part of us. And with our minds, we
create our own universe.
And as we discussed last class, this is
confirmed by neuroscience, by artificial
artificial intelligence, and by quantum
mechanics. So, it's really the dominant
understanding of human psychology we
have today.
All right? But the problem with Immanuel
Kant, there are three major issues with
Immanuel Kant. The first major issue is
if we can never know reality,
then how do we know
what's real and what's fake?
Right?
How do we know we don't live in a
computer simulation? And the answer is
we don't know. So, that's the first
issue with Immanuel Kant. He does not
give us proof of an objective reality.
Okay? That's the first problem. Second
problem is the source
for our reason. If we are born with the
capacity to imagine space and time and
shape our reality, who gives it to us?
Where does it come from?
And he doesn't really answer that
question.
Right? The third question is the problem
of uniformity.
Which is to say,
how do I know that you
and me and others see the world in the
same way?
Why aren't we seeing a a different
reality? Okay? And then and then
Immanuel Kant says, "Well, we don't know
either, okay?" So these these are the
three major problems created by Immanuel
Kant's philosophy of the world. So
Frederick Hegel comes along and resolves
all three issues.
And what he says is this. He says that
the underlying
source of reality is called the Geist.
The Geist is the spirit of the world.
Think of it as a god that's becoming
into reality. It's growing, okay? It's
almost like the internet. Uh collective
consciousness. And as a result, the
Geist is giving us the capacity to
reason and to see itself and then to
imagine own reality, okay? So the idea
of the Geist solves all three problems
at once. An underlying reality that
gives um
uh that creates the material reality. So
Hegel's an idealist, meaning for him
what matters is ideas and spirit.
And the material world is created from
these ideas and from spirit. Okay? So
these are the So what
does this is Hegel. What Karl Marx will
do is build on Hegel to create something
called dialectical materialism, which is
the idea of class struggle. Okay? And he
will create his philosophy based on his
reading of Hegel. All right. So, let's
um go over how Marx
interprets Hegel.
So, again,
Hegel has three
major
ideas. The first is the idea of the
Geist, okay? The underlying
superstructure of reality.
Second is the idea of the dialectic.
Okay. So, the idea of the dialectic is
how does this Geist become what it does?
What what it is? How does this Geist
learn and think? And the answer is the
dialectic. The dialectic is thesis,
antithesis,
and synthesis.
And the concept is just a debate among
in itself.
For it to know itself, it must create
its opposite. And then when it creates
its opposite, it debates itself and
creates a synthesis.
Okay? And it's the idea of a debate
where you might have a viewpoint and you
engage with someone with another
viewpoint that's opposite of yours, you
debate, and through this debate, you
create a synthesis of your different
viewpoints. Okay? And for Hegel, this is
the under under underlying logic of
history, of how we learn, of how we
progress, okay? And the third idea that
Hegel proposes is the idea of of the
master-slave
dialectic.
And so, um Hegel thinks
that relationship can be broken into a
master and slave.
Basically, I command you, you do as I
say, you obey me.
But when But then what Hegel says is,
"Over time,
this
thesis-antithesis also becomes a
synthesis. Why? Because as your master
as your master, I become dependent on
you as my slave.
In fact, you're the one doing all the
work. So, without you, I can't exist.
Okay? So,
in this way, the relationship inverts
itself. And the master becomes slave to
the slave, right? Because the master is
now dependent on the slave for his
livelihood. All right? So, those these
are the three big ideas that Hegel is
going to take Sorry, these are the three
big ideas of Hegel, and Marx is going to
take these three ideas and develop his
own theory of the world.
So, Marx
Marx is from Prussia.
Um
as we discussed
uh before, a lot of these major
philosophers are from Prussia. Hegel
himself was also Prussian. He was very
proud to be to be Prussian. Um and Marx,
when he was in university, was part of a
group called the Young Hegelians. These
are individuals, uh a group of them, who
worship Hegel, but they misinterpreted
Hegel, okay? They thought of Hegel as an
atheist, um because he said, "God is
dead." But, when Hegel said, "God is
dead," what he really meant is, "I am
now going to reinterpret God not as this
separate entity from us, but as part of
us in the form of the Geist." Okay?
Um so, the Young Hegelians will
reinterpret Hegel and basically
misinterpret him. So, the first thing
they do is they take the Geist and they
turn it into a material thing.
Okay? Economics.
So, Hegel thinks it's ideas that come
first, then materiality.
But, these guys, the Young Hegelians,
they will invert this and say, "It's
materiality that creates ideas." Okay?
It's economic, it's wealth that creates
culture, which gives rise to ideas.
Okay? So, it's the complete opposite.
Um second thing they'll do is, if this
is true, the dialectic in the
master-slave relationship, um then
history is a history of oppression
and a struggle for liberation against
this oppression. Okay? And so, the idea
of the
material world in struggle with itself
creates idea of dialectical
materialism.
And we call this
class struggle. Okay?
The rich and the poor fighting each
other and the poor are looking for
liberation. Right? So, does that make
sense? Yes. Okay, great. So, um that's
right. So, this is class struggle.
And this is the main contribution that
Marx will make and by creating this
idea, he will lay the foundation for
what we today refer to as communism.
All right? The underlying reality of
history is class struggle.
The other thing that Marx will take from
Hegel is an understanding that all of
history is theological. Okay?
Theological.
Okay, this is a big word, but all it
means is there is an an ability to
history. There's a purpose. There's a
progress to history. Everything is being
done for a reason, okay? So, let's go
over the theology that Marx creates. All
right.
So, we were born as hunter-gatherers. We
all know this.
Okay? We're out in the out in the forest
hunting food in small tribes. And we're
happy. But, there's not enough food to
feed everyone.
So, we develop agriculture.
Right?
And then because of agriculture, we have
something called surplus value. We're
able to create more wealth, which allows
a few of us to settle down
and do other stuff. For example, create
literacy.
Okay? And this gives rise to
civilization.
And then to justify the civilization, to
justify this hierarchy, the fact that
you have a few people who are
essentially parasites of society, we
create the idea of religion, right?
Because the elite now are priests.
All right? So, that's the second stage.
Then what happens
is
um as we develop more and more
technology and the societies become
larger and larger, we have to go to war
against each other.
Okay? To fight for resources. And so,
this gives rise to a master-slave
relationship,
which then gives us feudalism.
Okay? Which then allows for the rise of
industrial capitalism.
And this is a stage Marx finds himself
at.
And what Marx says is this is all a
linear progress driven by technological
advancement, right? So, agriculture is
an advancement, and then you have tools,
and you have weapons,
um then you have castles, knights, and
now you have steamships, okay? So, it's
all part of a
technological plan to liberate humanity.
Technology, okay?
Now, and he's writing in the year 1848,
okay?
Um
and now now industrial capitalism will
naturally lead to communism.
All right? He says this this is not
something that we can hope for
or work towards. It's something that's
going to happen because of history.
Okay? History is God. God is history. We
Our world is being developed through the
mind of God.
All right? So,
um first thing he does is he uses the
Hegelian dialectic, right? So, feudalism
is the thesis, industrial capitalism is
the antithesis, and then together they
will create communism.
Why?
Okay.
So, for Marx, embedded in capitalism
is
the
seeds of its demise. And there are three
reasons why.
Okay? First is
industrial capitalism
is imperial. It's all consuming. It
expands.
And as a result, it's going to create
a global proletariat.
And all oppressed,
they're going to come into consciousness
together and recognize that only through
collective action can we liberate
ourselves from the capitalist class.
All right? And because the proletariat
is the majority of people, 99%,
then the 1% have no have no chance.
Okay?
That's number one. Number two is the
idea of technology.
Capitalism gives rise to to new new
technology, which makes which creates
surplus value and surplus labor.
It basically makes our job easier, okay?
Which case, we don't have to work as
hard as before in order to create value.
Okay?
So, that's technology. So, for for
example, AI, right?
And the third is the idea of crisis in
capitalism.
Okay? Crisis in capitalism.
And what this means is for Marx,
capitalism is fundamentally
unsustainable. It will collapse at a
certain point. Why?
Well, there are many reasons why, okay?
So, for Marx, the main problem is
overproduction. You're producing all
these goods, but because you're
impoverishing everyone, no one's going
to buy these goods. In which case, the
market In which case, the economy's
going to collapse, right? That's one um
possibility. Another possibility is
presented by a man named Thomas Piketty,
okay? And he wrote a famous book called
Capital in the 21st Century. And he's
working off
Marx. And what he believes the
fundamental
uh paradox of capitalism is is a problem
of
uh
financialization.
So, all this is saying is this.
At first, we have to build a factory to
generate wealth, right? But once we have
generated enough wealth, we want to take
this wealth and go and invest it
somewhere.
Because it's easier for us and we can
make more money that way.
But over time, as capitalism grows and
grows, everyone wants to invest, no one
wants to manufacture.
And what happens then is the financial
economy is going faster than the
manufacturing economy.
In fact, for Piketty, the financial
economy will go up 5%, whereas the
manufacturing economy will go up 2%.
This means that if you put your money in
the stock market, you'll make 5% a year.
If you open a restaurant or you create a
factory
or you do something useful, you make 2%
a year. So, no one wants to work
anymore,
right? So, for Piketty, capitalism will
have to end at some point.
Then you have a name named Carroll
Quigley.
And he's a historian. Uh we discussed
him uh last week. But he's a historian
at Georgetown. He's dead. But he wrote a
very famous book called Tragedy and
Hope. And he argues that capitalism goes
in phases. The first phase is consumer
capitalism, where companies are trying
to create products that consumers want
to buy.
Then that leads to
financial capitalism, where now
companies just want to invest their
wealth.
But over time, the final stage is the
idea of monopoly capitalism, where a few
companies control all the resources.
Okay? In which case,
uh we pay a lot of money for crappy
stuff.
And then we don't want to buy anything
anymore, okay?
So,
um
for Marx and for Piketty and for Kelo
quickly, capitalism can only lead to
crisis.
And then because of the crisis, the
proletariat will organize
um and then rebel and then create a
workers' paradise, okay? Which leads to
communism.
That's the logic of Marx. That is Marx's
understanding of history.
Okay?
All right. So, what I'm going to explain
now is
why would this be popular? Why would
this history be popular for people?
Because communism was one of the most
popular movements
um throughout the 20th century, okay?
And
the problem that Marx diagnoses is
capitalism makes people miserable for
three reasons.
Okay? So, the issues of capitalism.
The first issue is that
it is all encompassing, all consuming.
So, in other words, it just grows and
grows. And because it has to grow and
grow to create value, it starts wars.
So, you have imperialism, right? Because
as a factory owner, you want to create
new markets, you want access to cheaper
goods, you want access to cheaper labor.
Therefore, you force your government to
go invade other countries like China,
India,
Africa. Okay? So, capitalism creates
wars and human misery all around the
world. It's all consuming. It's always
expanding. Okay? Second problem with
capitalism is that it is it
consolidates, consolidating.
And the idea here is this.
Capitalism
can only lead to extreme inequality.
Why? Because the point of capitalism is
to generate as much wealth as possible.
So, to do that, we want to consolidate
our wealth. So, maybe there's 10 of us
with a million dollars each, right?
Well, we're better off just put put put
our money together and then investing it
together.
Right? Which creates massive inequality.
So, over time, Marx believes that
because capitalism is all consuming and
consolidating, it would destroy the
middle class. Unless you're super
wealthy,
um you won't have any money, okay? If
you are just like a small factory owner,
you'll be bought up by a large factory
owner. And quite honestly, this is
what's happening in the world today,
okay? If you are a small house owner in
America, well, um you're going to be
bought up by a company. And then the
company's going to use your house to
rent to other people, okay? So, this
this is a pattern that's happening
throughout the world today. And that's
why Marx is seeing a massive resurgence
in our world today.
Right? Now, the third problem
um is alienating.
And here Marx explains that there are
four types of alienation, okay? The
first type of alienation is the
alienation of labor. What this means is
this:
As humans, we want to create stuff. We
are fundamentally creative. We want to
create art products. We want to cook. We
want to teach. We want to express our
individuality.
Okay? And what we want to do that is,
when we express our individuality, when
we create things,
we um support the community. Right? So,
when I teach uh you guys, you guys
learn. And when you learn, you
um feel good, you thank me, and that
confirms my humanity. That confirms my
individuality. So, society is a
mechanism for each of us to exchange
um
um our creativity in a way that affirms
our own individuality, okay? Does that
make sense?
All right? The problem with capitalism
is
it takes use value,
okay? What this thing is used for, and
replaces it for like exchange value,
okay? Which is how much this thing is
worth.
And that's this is These are two
different opposites, okay? Oh, sorry.
These are two different concepts. So,
use value is I cook I cook a apple pie,
and then I give it to you, and you eat
it, and you're like, "Wow, this is a
really awesome apple apple pie. Thank
you so much."
And then you feel good, I feel good,
okay? That's use value.
Exchange value is I cook this apple pie,
and I give it to someone who then goes
sells it to someone. I never meet that
person, okay? And I'm not And And I
don't know what happens to the pie, but
I'm paid like $5 for it.
All right? So, that's the idea of
exchange value. And as such, what Marx
is says is
this exchange of goods does not affirm
our individuality, therefore it makes us
miserable because we don't know why
we're doing anything anymore.
Okay? Before, we're doing things in
order to support our community, in order
to please other people, in order to to
affirm our humanity. Now we're just
making stuff because of wage labor,
right? Wages. To get paid.
Okay? So, that's alienating for us.
Okay?
This This makes sense, right?
Great.
Second is that it alienates us from
ourselves. Why? Because as human beings,
we are very complex, we are
multifaceted, and we're always evolving.
But for capitalism, what matters is
division of labor, okay? Specialization.
Because that's what allows for the most
rapid industrial growth. And so, in
other words, you cease to be you, and
you become a hand. Or maybe a finger, or
maybe an eye, or maybe an ear, okay? But
you cease to be complete. You just be
You're You're just like a cog in the
machine. You're just a piece of the
puzzle. And that alienates you from who
you are really. It'll It It prevents you
from achieving your full potential as a
creative, vibrant human being. Okay,
that's the second issue. The third issue
is it it alienates us from nature.
Okay? Why? Because
capitalism grows by exploiting humans
and by exploiting nature. It cuts down
trees. It destroys the environment. It
creates air pollution.
We we can no longer drink drink clean
water, okay? It destroys the nature and
it makes us feel like we must destroy
nature if we are to feed our families.
So, it alienates us from our nature,
whereas historically, we have feel we we
have been in a symbolic relationship
with nature where we thank nature for
feeding us, but we're always
replenishing, we're always protecting
nature.
Right? Now, fourth type of alienation is
the alienation from humanity.
All right?
So,
before from from most of history, we
were cooperating with each other, we
were helping each other out. Okay?
Because that's the only way you could
survive. But, capitalism forces us to
compete against each other. Okay? And
the example, of course, is school, where
because of grades, you see your
classmates as competitors.
Right? But, if there were no grades,
then you might help each other learn.
You might
um
tutor each other in in homework and help
each other with homework and tests.
Okay? Okay? So, so
that doesn't make sense. So, the idea
here is
let's just say that
um
like like maybe five people are have to
carry some goods to a store, okay?
That's that's your job. One person falls
down, breaks his leg, and cries out for
help. Well, we should go help that
person, right? But, the logic of
capitalism is that you can't The logic
of capitalism is you can't do that
because
the manager will fine you for being
late.
Okay? Does that make sense? All right?
So, that that That's why Marx thinks
that this will alien us from our
humanity. And this part of Marx, where
Marx diagnoses the problems of
capitalism, is considered brilliant,
okay? This is a perfect encapsulation of
all the issues with capitalism that was
true in 1850s, in the 19th century, but
it's also true today. If you look at the
world today, then we also have these
issues. And if you can if you analyze
Marx's da diagnosis of capitalism, then
it helps explain why the world is the
way it is.
Okay?
All right.
So,
and because of these pressing issues,
because people are suffering so much,
they see Marxism, they see communism as
salvation and redemption. That's the
appeal. Okay? Because the capitalism has
made life so miserable for a majority of
people.
Okay?
All right.
So, but the problem is we know
that
this
prophecy of Marx that we will naturally
evolve into communism
has not panned out.
In fact, communism has caused a lot of
human misery as well.
And so, why
is that the case?
And so, what I'm going to show you now
is
even though Marx has this beautiful
theory, it's also wrong. Okay? For a
variety of reasons. So, let's analyze
his understanding of history and show
how it's wrong. Okay? The first thing is
um let's go over to the hunter-gatherer
agricultural transition. The first class
I ever taught
um
like a long, long time ago is
the transition from hunter-gatherer to
agriculture didn't make any sense.
As a hunter-gatherer, you didn't have a
scarcity problem. In fact, you ate
really well. You worked less, you ate
more, and we know because if you dig up
skeletons of hunter-gatherers, they're
taller than farmers. In fact, they're a
lot taller.
So, hunter-gatherers were on average
like six six foot, okay, which is like
really, really tall. Right? And farmers
were like on average maybe five foot.
That's a huge difference.
Okay? So, the So, using the economic
argument of Marx, this makes no sense.
All right? And what I explained to you
before is it's not economics that drives
human history, it's religion that drives
human history. Okay? So, we settle down
in order to practice a cult, to practice
a religion, because maybe one place was
considered divine for whatever reason.
And as a result,
we develop our culture, which led to
civilization. So, the Marx formulation
that religion comes last is wrong. It's
religion that comes first, okay? It's
religion that leads to agriculture,
which leads to civilization.
All right? So, that's what Marx gets
wrong. Also,
um the transition from feudalism to
capitalism was not driven by technology,
it was driven by religion. All right?
So, let me explain.
Okay. So, the feudalism, the dominant
religion at the time was the Catholic
religion.
When we When we go into industrial
capitalism, the dominant religion is
Protestantism, okay?
So, as we discussed before, the Catholic
religion was an imperial bureaucracy,
uh led by the Pope. And there were many
religious reformers who thought this was
abhorrent. This went against the will of
God.
Okay? And so, what they proposed was
this.
They proposed a religion which was
democratic, in which everyone had access
to God.
Okay? Before you had to listen to the
priest, you can read the Bible by
yourself. Now, you had to read the Bible
by yourself in order to access God by
yourself, okay? And there were two major
different There were two major
transitions.
Um the first is, before
in order to get to heaven, you had to
use justification by works.
All this means is you do good things.
You give money to the church. You
probably give money to the church, okay?
All right? But because the Protestants
want to reduce the power of the Catholic
Church, they said, "No, what matters is
justification by faith."
It doesn't matter how much money you
give to the church. What matters is, do
you truly believe in God? Okay? That's
what matters. So, that's the first major
difference.
Uh and then
the Protestants in order in order to
reduce the power of the church
uh because the church said, "Only if you
listen to us can we guarantee you access
to heaven, right?"
So, what the Protestants said is, "No.
Um access to heaven is predestined uh
so, they have predestination.
In other words, at the beginning of time
God has already decided who will go to
heaven and who will go to hell.
He already decided. So, doesn't matter
what the church tells you. It doesn't
matter how much you money you give to
the church, you're all going to hell if
you don't believe truly believe in God.
All right? So, the so the Protestant
religion was a direct response to the
Catholic religion.
Now, this creates a new problem. Okay?
The problem is this.
How do you know you truly believe in
God?
How do you know that you are one of the
elect? How do you know that you were
chosen by God to go to heaven? This
creates anxiety, right? Anxiety, as you
know, leads to OCD, obsessive-compulsive
disorder.
Right? So, how do you compensate for
OCD? Well, you make a lot of money.
But not only do you make a lot of money,
but you don't spend it because that
wealth now is an indicator to you and to
others that you are truly one of the
elect, that you are saved by God, that
you were chosen by God to go to heaven.
And that's the birth of capitalism.
Okay? Does that make sense?
All right? It was not technology driven
because the technology at that time was
everywhere. But it was only in Europe
did you have industrial capitalism. It
was because of the Protestant faith.
That's what drove it. But why would
making
so much wealth can be a promise to
Okay.
Um so, you generating this wealth not to
appease God, but to appease your
anxiety.
Do you do you understand? This You won't
give money to this to God because God
doesn't need your money, okay? But
having this money is confirmation to
yourself
that you will go to heaven because this
money can only be made because of your
faith in God.
Do you understand?
Okay? How do you know you believe in
God? Because you worked hard and God
made you wealthy.
And that's the logic driving capitalism.
So Marx missed this.
Okay?
So um so let's summarize and say, "Look,
Marx made three fundamental mistakes.
The first is
people care about religion, not
economics, okay?
It's religion that drives human history,
not economics. That's the first mistake
he made. Second mistake that he made is
people care about God,
not heaven.
Okay? In other words, we're going to
heaven not because we think it's a
five-star hotel with like lots and lots
of like
I don't know, like lobsters and steaks
and all-you-can-eat buffets. That's not
the reason we're going to heaven. We're
going to heaven to be with God because
God represents eternal truth, eternal
salvation. We want to be with God.
Okay? The third is people care about
status,
not class.
So
in other words,
um
throughout most of of human history,
we didn't have a concept of money.
So for example, the Vikings,
um when they went off to steal, they
stole lots of gold, right? But the but
when they got back to the village, they
would host hold a big feast for
everyone. They would waste all this
money.
You understand?
Because the point because you there's
actually no point in having money. You
couldn't spend it.
If you died, you couldn't keep it.
So so you you made money, you generated
wealth in order to raise your status
within the community.
Okay? And that's why you wore gold
because the gold signified that you have
high status within the community.
All right? So throughout most of over
over human history and still even today,
we seek status, not class. The class The
concept of class is created because of
industrial capitalism, because of the
free market, okay?
Because now people were mobile.
Okay?
But before, it was about status. Okay.
And so,
what this means is this.
Because Marx interpreted history
incorrectly and he didn't really
understand human psychology.
What he could not predict is when we did
achieve communism, it would be it would
become
bureaucratic hierarchies with cults of
personalities.
In In the Soviet Union, you had Stalin,
right? He was in charge of a
bureaucracy.
And in China, you had Mao Zedong,
who had who was in charge of
bureaucracy. North Korea, the same same
same situation.
Why? Because of these three factors,
right?
Mao, Stalin all understood that people
want a religion.
They want to be They want to feel close
to God. So, they made themselves God.
Okay?
And people want status and that's why
it's important to have a bureaucracy.
So, that's why communism communism
became the way it became in the 20th
century.
All right?
Okay? So, does this make sense?
All right, great.
All right, so the the
So,
even though the Marx philosophy is very
appealing, it's very clear, it's very
direct, it's very sexy, he got the he
got the history wrong. And and and and
because he got the history wrong, the
consequences were huge, okay?
Because um communism created a lot of
wars and it led to a lot of disasters
like famines and stuff.
Okay?
Any questions be before I move on?
But, like
some of like folds of Marx is very
obvious. For example, like the the
emphasis on religion instead of the
economics. So, why communism can still
be so appealing to
to to to the world? And why especially
for like China China and like Soviet
Union such a culture? Okay. Yeah. So,
that's a really good question.
And so, the question is the world
religion should be obvious to people,
right?
Why do they believe in economics?
Okay. Okay.
Um
that's a great question. And
you know what? I don't have an answer.
But, I think a clue is this.
Capitalism and communism are the same
religion.
Okay? So, as capitalism grows, it
reinforces communism. As communism
grows, it reinforces capitalism. Why?
Because both believe that economics,
materialism, is the the underlying
reality.
Okay? Religion doesn't matter.
So, capitalism spreads by making
everyone uniform. By turning everyone
into an economic animal, right? Because
today, we don't ask you to believe in
God. We ask you to go buy things.
Does that Does that make sense?
Communism is the same way. Communism
believes that as long as there's
equality, as long as there's no
property, everyone will be happy.
So, it's ironic that these two ideas,
capitalism and communism,
even though they were moral enemies in
the 20th century,
the underlying basis of the religion is
the same.
And as they develop, they reinforce each
other, okay? That Does that make sense?
All right. So, but that that that That's
a great question.
All right. So, we instantly understand
that religion is more important than
economics. But, because capitalism and
communism were able to spread so fast,
we've been brainwashed into thinking
that only
economics matters.
Okay? So, for example, when you read the
newspaper, it's always what's the GDP
this year?
What's the employment rate this year?
What's the inflation rate this year?
What's the price of eggs this year? It's
never how do people feel spiritually?
How would how are how how are people
religiously? Okay? It's never about your
psychology. It's never It's never about
your spirituality. It's always about how
much money do you have?
Okay?
So, so communism and capitalism together
conquer the world.
Okay?
Does that make sense? Yeah. Okay, great.
Any more questions be be before I move
on? But why especially this kind of like
strategy is fit for
China or say Soviet Union, but not being
accepted by the Western world?
Okay,
this is a great question. So, Marx
himself
um believed the revolution will happen
in Germany first.
Because Germany had the most advanced
proletariat.
Um but it never happened in Germany. It
didn't happen in France. It didn't
happen in Britain. It happened in China
and the in Russia. And in fact, if Marx
were alive today, he'd be appalled by
the fact it happened in Russia and
China. Because it wasn't supposed to
happen in Russia and China. You needed a
proletariat in order for the revolution
to happen, but Russia and China were
peasant nations, right?
So, why did it happen in
um
uh Russia and China? Okay, the main
reason is this. Um and we'll go more
into this next week, okay? The main
reason is this. Because the communist
revolution was not a communist
revolution. It was a peasant revolution
with the veneer of communism.
So, communism was the ideology, the
religion that they practiced, but it was
essentially a peasant rebellion. That's
no different from previous peasant
rebellions in Chinese history.
Okay? Does that make sense?
All right. But but I'll explain this
later on, all right? Great. But great
question. Any Any more questions before
be before I move on?
Great.
All right. So, what was this clear to
you? This history, okay? All right,
good. And it's very important because
it really helps you understand the world
we live in today because even though
Marxist theory of history is wrong, his
understanding of capitalism is is
perfect, okay?
And it really helps you think about why
things are happening the way they are
today. Especially the concentration of
wealth. All right, let's do the history,
okay?
All right.
So,
um
Okay, we did Kant and Hegel
um on Tuesday. We're We're doing Marx
today.
Next Tuesday we do Freud, okay? Why are
we doing these four thinkers? Because
they're the ones
each of them who created intellectual
revolution that finally changed the way
we see ourselves and society.
Okay? So, remember, Kant made us
subjective, okay? He taught us that the
world does not exist outside us.
Hegel taught us that there's a Geist
that
uh compels us into Okay, we're we're
we're just a manifestation of this
Geist, okay? But the Geist is
everything. Marx teaches us teaches us
it's class struggle that's the
underlying force of history.
Okay? And what he also believes is the
class struggle can only end in
communism. Why? Because that is the will
of God because God manifests itself in
our history.
All right? So, Marx is really building
on top of Hegel. What we'll What we'll
learn next
Tuesday is Freud, okay? So, and Freud's
going to work on all three to build a
new theory of the world. And the theory
is
amazing because what he does is
um he takes all these theories and
teaches us that we are own universe.
Everything that happens is because of
our memories.
I'm not psychology, okay? But that's
next Tuesday. Um but just to give you
heads up. All right. So, um the entire
lecture is about why was Marx wrong?
Okay, and as explain, the writings of
Marx
I mean, he was like a prophet, right? Um
he comes from a Jewish family.
He himself uh was an atheist, but he
came from a long line of Jewish Jewish
rabbis.
And when I say that, you're like, "Okay,
that doesn't sound that impressive." But
it's basically the equivalent of saying
he came from 10 generations of Harvard
professors.
That's really impressive, right? So, I
mean, uh he was a genius. His entire
family were geniuses. Remember, the Jews
are very intellectual people. They were
the people of the book. And the rabbis
are the most intellectual members of the
community. They're the leaders of the
community. So, Marx comes from a
He's basically an aristocrat, okay?
Um So, he he's he's almost like a
prophet. I mean, he is a prophet. He's a
poet prophet who's preaching of a new
world to come.
And he's very
uh certain. He's very clear and he's
very optimistic. And that's his appeal,
okay? But as I explained, that's all
that was also his downfall. He was too
simple in his understanding of human
history.
All right.
So, um industrial capitalism is coming
to Europe and it makes everyone
miserable. Uh it's it's it's destroying
society because it's taking all these
people from the villages and
transporting into the cities with
without adequate housing, without
adequate health care.
Uh
um
work safety. They They're They're in the
slums. They don't have access to clean
water. A lot of them are dying. Um
Their children are being forced to work
um from age five or six.
It's all polluted, okay? So, people are
living in an misery, okay? Especially
children.
And this is causing a lot of anger. What
really does it is in 1840s, there's a
massive potato famine all across
Europe, okay? So, remember in the 16th
century, the Europeans, the Spanish
discovered the New World and they
brought back the potato. Why is that
important? Because the potato will allow
Europe to grow its population very, very
fast in order to
feed its economic needs. The problem
though is when you rely on a single
crop, the potato, it's prone to disease,
okay? So, the potato, because of its
lack of genetic diversity,
um it it it created a famine throughout
uh Europe. Tens of millions of people
died in this famine. And so, a lot of
them uh immigrated over to the New
World, America and South America, okay?
Uh the worst-hit part of Europe, of
course, was Ireland. So, as you can see,
only Dublin
managed to maintain or increase its
population. Everywhere else saw a
massive decrease
in its population. The red represents a
population decrease of 30% or more
in the span of a few years, okay? From
1841 to 1851, 10 years.
Okay, so
this was a massive traumatic event in
Europe and this led to
um sorry, this led to massive uprisings
throughout Europe, okay? And this is
what inspired
Marx and Engels to write the Communist
Manifesto
because they believed a new world was
coming and we have to prepare for it.
Okay? Now, what will happen is the 1848
revolutions are calling for three
things. They're calling for nationalism,
nation-states based on France, they're
calling for liberalism, more political
rights, and socialism, more worker
rights.
And it's all happening throughout
Europe, but and so Marx and Engels is
convinced
paradise is coming. But ultimately the
authorities cracked down, but Marx and
Engels are still convinced paradise is
coming at any point, okay? So they
dedicate their entire lives to um
um
imagining this new world.
The Communist Manifesto was published in
um in in in in anticipation of this
proletarian victory over the capitalist
class. Okay? And it is an amazing
document. It's beautifully written. I I
I don't think they get enough credit for
how wonderful this is written, okay? But
but but let's read the beginning. Right?
A specter is haunting Europe, the
specter of communism. So the specter is
important because remember, it's the
geist.
Right? Hegel said that the underlying
force of the world is the geist. And
what they're saying is the geist is
communism. Communism is the future. It
is what will happen.
Okay? All the powers of old Europe have
entered an into a holy alliance to
exercise the specter, Pope and Tsar.
Okay? So all the authorities of the
world are afraid of this geist, but this
geist is God, so it will triumph
eventually.
Okay?
Um
Let's read the end. To this end,
communists of various nationalities have
assembled in London and sketch the
following manifesto to be published in
the English, French, German, Italian,
Flemish, and Danish languages. This This
is really important because this is
one of the first international
revolutions.
It's going to sweep all around the
world. Okay? It will replace capitalism.
Capitalism is only the building block
for communism.
Okay.
Um the Communist Manifesto, it is
powerful.
Uh it's wonderfully written. It's
poetry.
And I think that over next few years as
the
cap uh uh economic crisis worsens around
the world, people are going to refer
back to the Communist Manifesto, okay?
But this is really the best part of
Communist Manifesto where Marx and
Engels diagnose the problems of
capitalism, okay?
The bourgeoisie, the capitalist class,
wherever it has got the upper hand, has
put an end to all feudal, patriarchal,
idyllic relations. It has pitilessly
torn asunder the motley feudal ties that
bound man to his natural superiors and
has left remaining no other nexus
between man and man than naked
self-interest, than callous self cash
payment, okay? So, remember, capitalism
it is an
all expanding, all encompassing, all
consuming, alienating force.
And it's destroying the world. But for
Marx and Engels, this is good because it
will lead to the rise of communism,
right? This is part of the thesis,
antithesis, synthesis part of history.
Um the So, the bourgeoisie are engaged
in imperialism. It's destroying all that
we've known before to create a new man,
an economic man, only based on
self-interest. It's even destroying the
family.
Okay? So, no you no longer see yourself
as a son or father or as a husband, you
see yourself as a man who makes $10,000
a year or $50,000 a year and you're able
to buy, I don't know, a car or whatever,
okay? So, that's the power of all
capitalism. But again, for Marx and
Engels, this is good because now it will
lead to communism
where this new consciousness will
transform into a class solidarity.
Okay?
This makes sense, right? Okay. So,
Marx's most famous work is Das Kapital
and he spent decades writing writing
this.
The problem with Marx is that he's a
brilliant man, he's he's one of the most
brilliant men who ever lived, but he's
extremely undisciplined. He
procrastinates all the time. So, he
actually never finished this book in his
life. It's Frederick Engels who
um
who was his best friend, his
collaborator, but Frederick Engels was a
very disciplined individual. So, it's
Frederick Engels who put this book
together. Okay?
All right.
All right. So, as I mentioned, what's
really important for us to understand is
that Marx, he's a prophet. He doesn't
think of himself as a prophet. He
doesn't know he's a prophet, but he's
really a prophet. And as such, what he's
really doing is he's just building on
top of Christianity.
Okay? He's just extending the logic of
Christianity.
Right? So, let let's see how the
Let let's see what he does. Christianity
is a passive religion. You don't really
have to do anything. Just don't commit
any sins and then you're going to
heaven, okay?
But, for Marx, what's important is that
we participate in the revolution, that
we are responsible for our lives.
Okay? Second difference is Christianity
argues that only a few can go to heaven.
You They argue about who will go to
heaven, but only a few, okay? Only a
minority of the people. Okay? That's why
you have he- hell, purgatory, and
heaven. Three different places. But, for
Marx, he believes that workers paradise
can be achieved for everyone. Okay?
Um and the third difference is
Christianity
offers a heaven of God. Marx offers a
utopia without God. The problem is this,
nobody wants a utopia without God.
Okay? We We discussed this where if
heaven was just a five-star hotel, where
you can eat all the best food in the
world, nobody would want to go. People
are going to heaven for God.
Okay? And this is why
uh Marx cannot anticipate the rise of
people like Stalin and Mao Zedong.
Okay.
Um this is a letter that Marx wrote in
his early years, and it is probably, in
my opinion, his best piece of writing.
Because it really shows you his
thinking, his optimism, his idealism.
Okay? So, so let's read it together.
Supposing that we have produced in human
manner, in this production each of us
would have doubly affirmed himself and
his fellow man. I would objectify in my
production my individuality and its
peculiarity and would thus have enjoyed
in my activity an individual expression
of my life and would have have also had
and look at the object the individual
pleasure of realizing that my
personality was objective. Okay? Does
that make sense?
So, you're creating something and this
thing is the perfect expression of your
individuality, of your personality, of
your creativity. And then you share with
other people and they enjoy it and that
and and because they enjoy it, that
process affirms your individuality and
your creativity. Your validation,
basically. Okay?
Right?
I would have been for you the mediator
between you and the species and thus
have been felt by you and acknowledged
as a completion of your own essence and
a necessary part of yourself and I would
then
thereby have realized that I was
confirmed both in your thought and in
your love. Okay? So, when I cook a meal
and you enjoy the meal,
um you're not only affirming my
individuality, but you're affirming my
connection to all of humanity.
Okay? Because you're telling me that I
contribute positively to the species.
Right?
Um
The problem is this. Pre-
Presupposing private property, my
individuality is so far externalized
that I hate my activity. It is a torment
to me and only appearance of an activity
and thus also merely a forced activity
that is laid upon me through an
external, arbitrary need, not an inner,
necessary one. Okay? So, this is
complicated, but all all he's saying is
this. I cook you a meal, I spend days
preparing this meal. Okay? I put It's a
labor of love.
I cook the best food in the world. Okay?
I give it to you.
You have You are a blown away. You are
you're in love, okay, with this food.
And then you're like
here's a thousand dollars.
Right? That's disgusting.
Right?
All you have to do is say thank you, but
instead you give me a thousand dollars.
And you think, "Wow, I'm getting a
thousand dollars. That's a lot of money,
man. I pay him I you know, I don't pay
this much at the restaurant." Okay? So,
that's what Marx is saying. The moment
you put money into the equation, it
destroys all human relations.
Right? So, he's talking about extrinsic
motivation where versus intrinsic
motivation. Intrinsic intrinsic
motivation is what makes us
fundamentally human.
Extrinsic motivation is what makes us
slaves.
Okay? So, that's what Marx is saying.
Capitalism makes us slaves because it
deprive deprives us of our humanity.
Okay? That's what money does.
So,
so does it make sense to you? Yeah.
Great. All right.
So, again,
um let's just summarize what the
failings of capitalism are, okay? Uh it
creates inequality, it exploits, and it
alienates.
All right. So, for Marx and Engels, the
synthesis will be class solidarity.
And this will lead to a classless
workers' paradise. Okay, that's the very
logic of Marxism.
Um so, again, Marx, what he will do is
he will invert Hegel, right? So, for
Hegel, it's the ideas that come first.
Then this will lead to the material
reality.
For Marx, it's the material reality that
gives rise to ideas, okay? What what So,
the ideas are the superstructure, the
base
uh the base is the economics. Okay? So,
this is a very important idea
of um
Marx. So, Marx diagnoses the problems of
capitalism really, really well, okay?
And he offers
solutions.
And what's really important is
one reason why communism has failed is
capitalism has actually adopted a lot of
these policy changes, okay? Including
universal child education, including
uh the universal right to work,
including abolition of child factory
labor, okay? So, in many ways communism
has won out.
And Marx didn't really predict this
because he thought that capitalists are
idiots. Capitalists all they care about
is money. So, they're like servants to
capital.
They're not really in control.
And if you're a capitalist and you have
any
empathy for the working class, guess
what? You're bought out or you're pushed
out
of the capitalist class, okay? So, it's
only the worst people who can thrive
within the capitalist system.
But because communism was such a huge
threat
to the ruling elite,
they had no choice to make compromises,
okay? And that's why after World War II,
most countries in the world became
socialist, even though in name they were
still capitalists.
Okay, so let's we summarize, and this is
really important for us, okay?
But what are the four things Marx got
wrong? Okay? The first thing is
Marx believed that history is a linear
progress. It's it's a straight line of
in inevitability of progress. But that's
not true, okay? History repeats itself.
That's the first issue. Second issue is
um
Marx believed in the inevitability of
history.
But there's always randomness built into
history, okay? Things happen and we
don't expect these things to happen.
Third is
Marx believed class struggle was
everything, but people care actually a
lot more about religion than they care
about economics.
All right? And you know, this is a huge
issue in America because with the rise
of Donald Trump,
then the Democratic Party
they don't know what to do about this.
Because they're like, you know, Trump
says that he will lower the price of
eggs, but he hasn't lowered the price of
eggs. So, like, stop voting for him.
And what the Democrats don't understand
is
people want to believe in God. People
want a leader. People want a religion.
And Trump, for all his feelings, he
understands that and gives people what
they really want, which is emotional
solidarity.
Okay, a belief in a better world.
Last thing, Marx believed a vanguard
needed to lead the proletariat into into
a paradise.
Okay, so Marx really believed that you
need an elite of intellectuals,
scientists, technocrats to create the
perfect society.
But then the question is, why would they
give up power?
Right? Once they had Once they have this
power, why would they give it up? And
the answer is, they wouldn't give it up,
okay? And that's why communism
ultimately fails in the Soviet Union and
in China, okay?
All right?
This makes sense, right? All right. So,
let's So, let's So, let's um
go into specifics.
Um
in this class, what you learn is it's
not class struggle by itself that causes
discontent. It's three other things,
okay? The first is elite overproduction.
So, a really important principle is
history is not fought over between the
poor and the rich.
It's fought over between the very rich
and the not so rich.
Okay? The upper nobility and the lower
nobility.
Right? Because Marx came from Jewish
aristocracy. Engels, his father was a
very wealthy capitalist. Okay? These are
people with a lot, and they wanted more.
Does that make sense?
So, when you have too many people
seeking too much wealth and status, it
creates conflict.
Okay? That's the first thing. Second
thing is the idea of a rat utopia, where
people live too long.
They live too long, they refuse to give
up power, they refuse to innovate.
They refuse to cede status to the young,
okay? The third is the idea of
financialization, as we discussed on
um Thomas Piketty and Carroll Quigley
provide this idea where over time, to
make more to make more money, all
capitalists will do is force everyone
into more debt.
Okay? And these are the three factors
that cause society to um ultimately
destabilize.
Right?
Clear?
Great. All right.
So, let's look at three examples, all
right? You look at Soviet Union, you
look at
um China, you look at France.
How was it possible for Soviet Union to
defeat Germany? And Germany was at that
time the most advanced military in the
world, right?
How did China the Chinese economy boom
after Cultural Revolution?
And how did Napoleonic France defeat all
of Europe, okay? So, what we need to
understand is these were not communist
revolutions. Okay? These were just
revolutions
that destroyed the old elite. And all
this is saying is this:
People are playing a game in society.
Over time, you have a few winners who
monopolize this game. And this causes
discontent. What revolutions do is they
reset the game.
And that creates a lot of energy,
right? Because people now want to work
hard to win the game. Because of this
energy, they're able to defeat their
opponents.
It's the same thing with the Cultural
Revolution, where the Cultural
Revolution removed the old elite, the
bureaucrats. So, in the 1980s, when
China opened up, you had the young
people with entrepreneurial drive
to start companies.
But without the Cultural Revolution,
this entrepreneurial our our our
entrepreneurial drive could not have
succeeded. Okay? Does that Does that
make sense?
All right.
Um
this is really complicated, okay? But
for Marx, the only what gives rise to
industrial capitalism and the
bourgeoisie is just technology and the
progress of history. But as we learn
this class, it's actually much more
complicated than that, okay? So, this is
really important, okay? What What What
we're going to do is we're going to
review what we learned previously and
put them together to explain what gave
rise what gave rise to industrial
capitalism. First thing is the
monotheistic revolution. Okay? So,
remember
before societies were paganistic or
polytheistic. Then with Constantine um
God became the Holy Trinity. Okay? The
Holy Trinity is the worst idea in human
history. The Holy Trinity is this.
God is nothing and everything.
Okay?
And what this means is God is both real
and not real. God is a symbol and
reality itself. And because of this
idea, people are now forced to think
abstractly about the world. And this
gives rise to money, nation-state, and
science.
Okay? People are now forced to think
abstractly about the world. Whereas
people were were before could think very
concretely about the world. Okay? Does
that make sense? All right. Se- Second
thing is gunpowder revolution where
nation-states, countries were forced to
compete against each other, which led to
more industry, more population growth,
and more centralization. And this paved
the way for the bourgeoisie.
Okay? Because now you need the
bourgeoisie to produce industry.
Okay?
And the third is the Protestant
Reformation. We discussed this, right?
Where you now have anxiety created by
this new religion.
And they needed to
uh force themselves to believe
they are the elect. Okay? And then the
Age of Exploration where the old world
Europe could go and create new markets
and steal new steal gold and bring the
corn, and tomato back into Europe, which
allows for population growth. Okay?
Okay. So, in other words, history is a
very complicated process with a lot of
randomness built in.
And this is something that Marx didn't
really understand.
All right?
All right.
So, to summarize, what people want is
status, not class. Okay? People want to
feel distinguished, feel superior, feel
uh that they've achieved a great deal.
The money doesn't really matter. The
money is just a symbol of this.
Okay?
People want religion, not economics.
People want God, not heaven.
Okay? And and the proof again is what
happens
um
when communism wins. Okay? So, both the
Soviet Union and China became
theocracies with cults of personalities.
Okay? They were not communist societies,
they were theocracies.
They were religious.
They were no different in many ways than
Catholic Europe during the
during the Middle Ages, okay?
Um Soviet Union fell apart because the
party elite no longer believed in the
system and chose to monetize their
status and power.
Okay? And then the third example is
North Korea has a fertility rate of
1.79, while South Korea South Korea has
a fertility rate of 0.78, okay? So,
North Korea it is a theocratic society,
South Korea is a capitalistic society.
Um so, what do you mean by the cult of
the with personality? Oh, cult of
personality is you believe this person
is the manifestation of God.
All your hope, all your emotions are
invested in this one person.
Right? So, um
so, Stalin, right? His pictures were
everywhere. And in school, you learn
about how great he was. You worshipped
him. He was God to you. But same thing
with China during the Mao Zedong era,
okay? Does that make sense? So, we call
this a cult of personality.
Okay? Like a new religion based on one
person. All right.
Um so, North Korea, which is poorer than
South Korea, has more children.
Right? Why? Well, because
people in North Korea and so- sorry, in
South Korea are miserable. They have
money, but they don't have religion.
They don't have a purpose. They don't
have any meaning. It's all competition.
Okay? So, this is like capitalism run
amok.
Um then you go to
North Korea, and he's president, okay?
He's dead, but he's still present. Why?
Because he's divine. He's God. He is the
forever present, okay? Kim Il-sung,
okay?
Right?
Um and
I mean like I have to say this, but if
you go to North Korea, they're probably
happier than they are in South Korea,
okay?
And um the other thing about North Korea
is they're not fighting Ukraine.
So, these are people who are willing to
die for what they believe in.
So, I would say if if I had to bet which
nation
um had the best future, I would bet
North Korea over South Korea.
Okay. Um let's talk about
um the vanguard idea. So, for Marx, a
really important idea is you need a
intellectual elite to lead the
proletariat into paradise.
And and this is this is a name name uh
man named Mikhail Bakunin, okay?
Bakunin.
Um and he was an anarchist. He was he
was not he was not a communist, he was
an anarchist. The difference is this,
they both believe in the same thing,
Marx and Bakunin, but Marx said you need
a vanguard. Whereas, Bakunin said, "No,
a vanguard would destroy everything."
Okay? It has to be spontaneous. It has
to be from the people.
Okay?
Um
Bakunin is also lower nobility. His
father was a uh Russian aristocrat.
Uh and Marx and Bakunin,
they were colleagues, but they hated
each other.
Right?
All right.
Um
So, Bakunin believes a lot of things
that Marx believes, right? The freedom
of every other individual does not limit
my own as the individualist claim. On
the contrary, it is confirmation,
realization, and human dignity of all
persons to see and feel my freedom
confirmed, sanctioned, and honestly
expanded by universal agreement is
happiness. It is human paradise on
Earth. So, for freedom to be fully
achieved, everyone must be free.
Everyone must be equal. Otherwise,
um no one can be truly free.
All right. So,
um Bukharin will explain why
a bureaucratic elite will destroy
communism. All right? So, this is a very
important passage from Bukharin.
"Available to everyone will be a general
scientific education, especially the
learning of a scientific method, the
habit of correct thinking, the ability
to generalize from facts and make more
or less correct deductions. But of
encyclopedic minds and advanced
sociologists, there will be very few. It
would be sad for mankind if at any time
theoretic speculation became the only
source of guidance for society. If
science alone were in charge of all
social administration, life would wither
and human society would turn into a
voiceless and servile herd. The
domination of life by science can have
no other result than the brutalization
of mankind."
Okay? This is a very important passage.
All he's saying is this,
before we were intellectuals, we were
curious about the world. Now we are
technocrats, we're engineers. We're
taught a very specific skill, and we're
taught to see the world in a very
specific way.
Okay? And we're run by technocrats.
And this has led to the brutalization of
mankind, because it has led to
the alienation of mankind, right?
We are now just parts
of a machine.
So,
um the example, of course, is AI. So,
these people in charge now want to make
AI the dominant religion of the world.
They want us to They want to make humans
slave to AI.
Okay? And that's what Bukharin is
warning against. Anytime you let a
bureaucratic elite take over,
they will think of ways of how to
reinforce their power through
technology.
And this has led to the rise of AI.
Okay? This
Does it make sense? Yeah. Okay? And this
is describing China very well.
Right?
The bureaucrats in charge,
they are they have no imagination. They
have no empathy.
All they care about is, okay, are we
checking checking off the boxes? Do you
have enough food to eat?
Right? Do you have a job?
Well, if you have a house, if you have a
job, you have health insurance, WHY ARE
YOU COMPLAINING?
RIGHT?
SO, that's what what we kind of say.
All right.
Um the last thing I want to talk about
is this. And you brought this up
earlier, okay? This is a good question
is
the question we're we're looking at
today is, why is China so similar to
America? Right? America is a capitalist
nation, China is a communist nation.
But if you talk to Chinese people today,
they all want to go to America to study
and possibly even to live. Chinese want
to become American.
So, in many ways,
America has conquered China.
And so, why is that the case? And the
answer, and I mentioned this before, is
it's because
communism and capitalism reinforce each
other. They share similar
ideology. They share similar background,
okay? They're all actually branch of
Christianity, really, if you think about
it, okay? They share and they have a
similar worldview, right? A belief in
progress, a belief in class struggle, a
belief that you need a technocratic
elite to run the world.
All right? So, in other words, communism
in China paved the way for American
capitalism. And that's why today you
have this going on, okay?
What China is doing to children is
unconscionable.
Right? Because we make kids sit in
school for like 10 hours a day. They
have no childhood. They have no freedom.
They have no happiness.
Um
most of these kids will
um they'll have depression by age 14,
right? The ma- ma- By my vast majority.
There la- last week there was there's a
huge news that a 9-year-old kid in
Beijing
killed himself.
9 years old.
Yeah, jumped off a building.
Um
That's that's incredible because my
oldest son he's like seven turning
eight, okay? I can't I mean I mean like
how miserable does did he have to be to
want to kill himself?
Right? Even if
the kid succeeds and goes to like Beida
or Qinghua,
he'll develop depression because he'll
never achieve what he wants in life,
okay? So all that's happening is we're
forcing our kids into depression, into
suicide.
Why? Because
this has become an evil religion almost.
Right? The belief that through education
you can make more money.
And even though everyone else will
probably develop suicide what what will
probably probably develop suicide or
depression you won't, okay? That's
that's that's I'm betting you won't,
okay? It's it's it's it's insane. I mean
what what what's happening
in education today it it it's just
unconscionable and evil what we're doing
to our children in China.
All right? And
why we're doing this is because
in China we've combined communism and
capitalism to create the worst possible
society, okay?
All right? All right, so um yeah.
Any questions?
Yeah, I have a question to the previous
content. It's like Yep.
the
uh I'm talking about like the the North
Korea, if they really like have such
kind of power even some somehow like
like Nazis they also have like kind of
like
uh
well of immunity and why they are still
suffering from the poverty, why they're
still
so
like
backward.
Uh okay, so why is North Korea so poor?
Okay, um
so
that's part of the capitalist
brainwashing.
Where you measure the success success
success of a society based on its
wealth.
Okay? But wealth is really
um just the willingness to exploit your
resources.
Okay? And also your capacity to engage
in global trade. So first of all, North
Korea is heavily sanctioned. They're not
allowed to trade with the world.
Okay? That's the first problem.
Um second problem is
um
they focus on their religion is is
called self-reliance.
They want to be independent of the
world.
Okay? So they purposely choose not to
engage in the world in order to maintain
the unity of their people. Okay? So
that's why we we call them the hermit
kingdom.
For for them, what's important is to
maintain their independence and
sovereignty from
from from from the world.
And
but
that does not mean people are not happy
where they are.
Okay? I would argue that even though
China was a lot poorer during the
Cultural Revolution, people were a lot
happier during the Cultural Revolution
than they are today. Maybe not maybe not
not us, okay? But for most ordinary
Chinese, they were a lot happier during
the Cultural Revolution
um than they are today because for them
life was simple and clear and certain.
Um today you have globalization, you
have the internet, you have noise, you
have you have it's very confusing for
people.
Right? And one piece of evidence is
young people don't want to have any
children today, whereas during the
Cultural Revolution, people did want to
have children because they felt that
regardless of poverty, people were into
a certain life.
They had health care. They had a job
guaranteed for them. They had a sense of
community. There was solidarity going
on.
Okay? So,
um that really is the trick of
capitalism to make everyone think the
same way, which is like money's
everything.
Okay?
Does Does Does that make sense? Yeah.
Great. Any more questions?
These are great questions, by the way.
So, so, so thank you for for for asking
them.
Won't Won't Marx spill himself
a bit of too idealistic?
Yeah.
Um
So, was Marx too idealistic?
Marx didn't think it was idealistic. He
thought it was extremely realistic.
Why? Because he was studying all this
history. He was studying all this
economics.
And he was coming up with a scientific
understanding of the world.
Marx saw himself as a scientist first
and foremost. He saw him- himself as
unveiling the truth to people.
Right? He was Do Do Do you Do you
understand? For him, it was science. It
was certain. It was It had to happen.
Okay? Um but the thing about Marx is
this.
Marx is also a person that if you if you
were to like jump forward today
and he saw the world created by
communism capitalism,
he'd be utterly disgusted.
He wouldn't be like, "Oh, wow, I'm
famous now. I, you know, I'm the most
famous person one most famous person or
I'm like Jesus, okay?" He He wouldn't be
like that. He'd be like,
"What have we done to humanity?
THIS IS FAR worse than the Industrial
Revolution what's happening where
everyone now is a is a slave as a
consumer, right? In your mind, all that
matters is I go to school,
I make a lot of money, I buy a lot of
things. That's it.
And this would have been unimaginable
to Marx and anyone actually 100 years
ago.
Okay, it's it's it's it's a fact that
humanity has chosen
to enslave themselves
for like no particular good reason.
Okay? And so,
the question then what we're looking at
next class is why does happen? And what
I will show you next class is Sigmund
Freud had a lot to do with this.
Psychology had a lot to to do with this.
Because before we were focused on the
collective consciousness, right? The
world as it is.
The community. But with coming of Freud
and psychology, we now shift our focus
to ourselves.
So, we come to believe that for our own
internal struggle,
we can be happy.
Others don't matter. We ourselves, if
we're happy, we're good.
And what
Buchanan and Marx have taught us is if
if everyone is unhappy, you must be
unhappy as well.
It's only if people are free and happy
together, can they be free and happy by
themselves.
Okay? And that's the thing that we
forgotten. And that's what's led to the
world we live in today. Okay? Well,
that's something that we'll discuss next
class.
Okay? Any more questions?
Great. Okay, so
uh Freud next class.